hey Vsauce Michael here every cloud has
a silver lining
except nuclear mushroom clouds which
have a lining of strontium 90 cesium 137
and other radioactive isotopes upon
detonation atoms are literally gutted
and glutton at temperatures exceeding
that of the surface of our Sun in the
1950s Harold Edgerton strapped a tronic
camera caught nuclear fireballs less
than a thousandth of a second after
detonation using a special magnetic
shutter each exposure lasted only a
billionth of a second and captured an
otherworldly creature its energy
vaporizing the metal wires supporting
its tower into stringy legs of plasma
watch the target on the ground now
roughly visualized here is a
conventional TNT explosion now on the
same spot a similarly sized bomb that
uses nuclear fission
[Music]
when little boy was detonated over
Hiroshima only one point three eight
percent of its uranium actually
fissioned the rest was blown away before
that could happen which means as Eric
Schlosser points out the fission of
merely point seven grams of uranium
that's less than the weight of a
banknote was enough to kill 80,000
people and destroyed two-thirds of his
city's buildings when a country has tens
of thousands of nuclear weapons ready to
go accidents are a possibility this was
a problem during the Cold War and it
still is a problem what if there is a
fire or a miscommunication or a rogue
officer decides to set one off or what
if someone just drops a warhead how much
risk is too much I asked Schlosser the
acceptable probability of a nuclear
weapon accident No
what is it now the acceptable
probability of the detonation of a
nuclear weapon in an accident is one in
a million in 2012 the odds of your dying
in a commercial airliner accident were
about 1 in 40 million so that's even
more remote than the accidental
detonation of a nuclear weapon
there have been upsie-daisy moments with
nuclear weapons on US soil luckily none
that resulted in critical mass but
accidents nonetheless just like when you
pee your pants except your pants are the
entire planet and the P stands for
plutonium Eureka comes from ancient
Greek meaning I have found it and in
Eureka North Carolina you can find it a
giant sign that says nuclear mishap on
my birth date the year my father was
born a USB 52 bomber carrying 2 4
Megaton thermonuclear bombs over North
Carolina
tumbled from the sky a loose lanyard in
the cockpit snagged the bomb release
switch each bomb contained a greater
explosive yield than all munitions ever
detonated by mankind combined lieutenant
Jack Ravel discovered that only one
safety mechanism didn't fail that day a
single low-voltage arming switch
remained untouched during the crash and
that once which is why he explained in
2011 we don't have a bay where North
Carolina is today the bombs were
recovered mostly the uranium rich
secondary of one of the bombs was never
found
to this day it remains buried
underground in North Carolina here's
something you can try at home
build a nuclear reactor in 1994 a
17-year old David Hahn attempted to
build a nuclear reactor in his mother's
backyard in Michigan it wasn't that
difficult for instance common everyday
smoke detectors contain small amounts of
radioactive americium and old
glow-in-the-dark paint contains radium
his reactor never reached critical mass
but it did succeed in exposing his
neighborhood
to 1000 times the regular dosage of
background radiation it was declared a
Superfund hazardous materials cleanup
site and all of his work was confiscated
by authorities and buried in Utah it
didn't end there in 2007 David Hahn was
arrested for stealing smoke detectors
from an apartment building his face was
covered with sores believed to be caused
by constant exposure to radioactive
materials
three days after little boy was dropped
on Hiroshima by the Enola Gay
Charles Sweeney was ordered to drop fat
man on Kokua he flew boxcar over the
city for nearly an hour with the bomb
bay doors open but it was cloudy sweeney
couldn't achieve visual confirmation of
the target and was forced to go to the
secondary target Nagasaki where 75,000
people died instead cocora was spared
because of the clouds
we can build a weapon that mimics the
furnace of our Sun and the winds of
Neptune but yet we can't predict the
weather more than a few minutes ahead of
time during World War two Japanese
soldiers fought for their Emperor in
ways that made Allied troops speechless
kamikaze planes and torpedoes driven by
a single pilot lost after use when
outnumbered without hope Japanese
soldiers were reported to have thrown
themselves off cliffs or swam out to sea
to drown rather than surrender even
after two atomic bomb attacks the
Japanese Minister of War urged his
people to continue fighting but on
August 14th 1945 the Emperor of Japan
overruled that decision and
unconditionally surrendered men had lept
off of cliffs for him but in his own
words the enemy has for the first time
used cruel bombs the heavy casualties
are beyond measure Richard Fineman
received the Nobel Prize in Physics in
1965 he also helped develop the first
atomic bomb at Los Alamos in the meaning
of it all he wrote is science of any
value and below that I think a power to
do something is of value he elaborates
by talking about keys everything we
learn about the universe everything we
invent or discover within it is a key to
the gates of heaven
but the same key will also open the
gates to hell the Titan 2 missile is
great for delivering lethal nuclear
warheads but it also sent Gemini
astronauts to space preparing us for a
mission to the moon science doesn't tell
us how to use keys it finds them or
predicts them how we use keys is up to
us and as always thanks for watching
[Music]